And if you import 1 person from Nigeria,
perhaps integrates,
maybe it is even 1 Christian persecuted
and integrates perfectly.
But if you matter
200,000 Nigerians from 1 of the most insecure countries
and where the Christians of the world are most persecuted,
you will have jihad here
you will have persecution of Christians wherever you bring them.
And you don't want to bring 200,000.
They have said,
and Mr.
Escrivá himself has said so,
than in the coming years,
and so has the iref,
want to bring 7 million people from these countries.
Of course,
the social configuration will change,
of course,
demographics are GOING to change,
of course they will change
the streets where Spaniards live.
If you bring massively people
of places where women are treated as objects,
here they will also treat women as objects.